et jean va terminer cette table ronde
merci avec jérôme a témoigné sur un
concept alors qu'on connaît bien en
france mais qui aujourd'hui prend de
l'ampleur en europe et et qui peut-être
une réponse à à des difficultés de
certaines filières françaises
aujourd'hui oui je commencerai juste
pour faire la transition à dire que nous
sommes un secteur qui aime bien les
états unis puisque c'est le plus premier
marché mondial du vin et que lui il
abandonnait la prohibition
ceci est ceci étant dit on a parlé ce
matin de l'entreprise agricole
on a parlé ce matin de l'économie il
faut aussi parler du marché et dire
faire croire aux agriculteurs qu'il y
ait un avenir à l'agriculture française
sans que la priorité soit le
développement des marchés
c'est une illusion est un mensonge et la
fonction essentielle de
l'interprofession kit filières
confondues avec des modes d'organisation
extrêmement différents c'est de
réconcilier la production avec le marché
de l'aider que les membres des filières
travail entre à converger vers le marché
et donc le revenu agricole mais aussi le
revenu des différents échelons de la
filière alors pour faire ça il a fallu
d'abord exister à bruxelles existait ça
voulait dire s'organiser ma filière nous
sommes présents physiquement depuis plus
de trente ans nos collègues des fruits
et légumes qui ont été aussi précurseur
et fruits et légumes frais et
transformés avait des bureaux à
bruxelles depuis plus de 30 ans et par
hasard c'est ces deux filières qui ont
vu leurs systèmes interprofessionnelle
reconnu les premiers cfc2 filière étant
généreuses elles ont fait don de leur
corps au reste des autres filières
attentes et si bien longue
aujourd'hui nous avons à nous nous avons
un système interprofessionnelle
horizontale au sein de la réglementation
européenne
il faut arrêter d'être masochiste sur la
capacité la france et faire progresser
des dossiers à bruxelles
simplement j'ai glissé bien il ya
quelques règles pour y arriver
le premier c'est qu'il faut être clair
entre nous les professionnels l'état
l'administration va pas à bruxelles avec
15 positions
on a mis du temps sur le dos et
interprofessionnelle mais on s'est
équilibré entre les terres les
administrations et toutes les filières
seconde c'est qu'il faut travailler nos
partenaires européens
on ne peut pas imposer la france a perdu
beaucoup beaucoup de crédit ces quinze
dernières années à bruxelles
on ne peut pas imposer dans une robe par
ailleurs 28 ce qu'on veut où on veut
comme c'était moi j'ai connu quand j'ai
commencé à travailler à trente ans
gillet champagne cognac bordeaux ont dit
oui monsieur fait de textes et on vous
suivra surtout si vous ne demandez pas
d'argent aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
possible
on est obligé d'arriver avec une
solution qui d'une part soit fongible
dans la politique de nos partenaires et
d'autre part soit accepté par oh ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
après l'existence et donc la
reconnaissance
il faut pouvoir s'organiser angelica
viens de parler d'un point extrêmement
important
c'est l'adaptation du droit de la
concurrence à l'agriculture c'est
totalement vital qu'on dira
l'agriculture doit respecter des
principes de concurrence parce
qu'autrement le marché ne fonctionnera
pas on peut pas faire 50 citadelle
agricole fermé les unes sur les autres
c'est totalement absurde mais simplement
le marché agricole et les marchés
agricoles
je crois que oui gère une vingtaine de
productions salle interfel
nous gérons nous 4 100 appellations
d'origine les marchés agricoles sont
tellement différencier qu'ils doivent
avoir des règles de concurrence
appropriées et c'est une des priorités
enfin je crois qu'il faut aussi qu'il y
ait des politiques vigoureuses et parler
monsieur du développement et de la corée
les états unis il faut que nous soyons
préserver sur notre marché national pas
de façon anti concurrentielles mais qu'
il ya une fierté de consommer nos
produits nous ne pouvons nous développer
sur les marchés extérieurs que si nous
sommes reconnus sur le marché mondial la
loi evin pour ma filière a fait rigoler
le monde entier et dernièrement il faut
cliquer une ocm adapter le cema reconnu
les interprofessions mail vous
reconnaître leurs moyens de preuve
le droit de la concurrence et enfin une
politique qui permette le développement
des produits
louis en a parlé il faut qu'on arrête
d'opposer les produits l'europe les
entreprises
tout ça doit travailler ensemble et
converger vers un développement sur le
marché qui seul assurera un revenu à nos
agriculteurs
merci jérôme ce fut un propos très
clairs et est très con si je crois qu'il
ya matière effectivement de à mener une
réflexion pour la prochaine politique
agricole commune au travers des
témoignages que vous nous avez apporté
et je vais tout de suite vous remercier
les uns et les autres est proposé à ces
jean-pierre je crois costes qui voit là
où jean-louis pardon excusez moi j'ai
encore pas familiarisés avec tout le
monde